so we noticed that your film has
different pricing points on these
different platforms can you tell us the
impact of that and your thoughts on it
yeah you know you're always
experimenting right so you can watch our
film for two dollars straight on our
website you can rent it on vimeo for two
dollars we have a five dollar rental
package or a six dollar rental package
where you can rent all the content me
you know all the content that's on the
DVD you can rent you can buy all the
content I think for ten dollars so it's
like or you can buy a DVD you know for
eleven dollars right now on amazon so
you wonder you wonder okay well is it a
money is it a money thing it will you
get more people buying your film or
interacting with your film if it was
more accessible and so you try lowering
the access down to a point where what
more can you do to make it more
accessible we have the film up on amazon
i think it's for two dollars you can
just rent it on amazon or on hulu right
now you can watch the entire film on
hulu but guess what there's eight
minutes of advertising that's also
thrown in there which to me is a viewer
i wouldn't enjoy but maybe people are so
used to that people are maybe used to
watching content with advertising that
it's okay it's hard it's hard you know
really i should just serve a maybe i
should go out there and be like how do
you watch content how do you watch
content and do that because i don't
think i found it yet I don't think I've
found the right spot to exist yet
completely
you